This is Jocko podcast number 12 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Sometimes people ask me,
what made me
me?
How did I turn out like this?
Where did that come from?
And I go back and I,
I pointed,
you know,
hardcore music growing up and it being in that scene where it was cool to be
hard and strong and it was about aggression and discipline.
And those were like the underlying theme saw it.
I pointed that,
you know,
and I think that's real.
There was mantras that I remember from those days that stuck with me,
my,
my whole life from some of those,
from some of that music.
Well then there's other things that influenced me as a kid and even even a
younger age.
And one of the things that I know influenced me at a very young age in a pretty
significant way was seeing the movie bridge on the River Kwai,
which is a classic war movie.
And that movie
pretty much had it all for me.
And I think I can trace my ideas of being a commando,
how to use that word.
You know,
that's kind of a archaic word that people don't use anymore commando.
But I think I got it from watching that movie when I was a kid.
And if you haven't seen that movie,
you should check it out for sure.
Because it's epic and it's a story of prisoners of war and American and British,
mostly British that are sent to build a bridge in the middle of the jungle in
Burma for a train line that is to connect Bangkok and rang goon.
And of course these are prisoners,
so they're badly mistreated,
they're beaten,
they're poorly fed.
Eventually one American escapes
and he leads a commando troop back to the side of the bridge to blow up the
bridge.
And they do it all at the commandos and a movie.
They do it all,
they parachute in and they swim up the river.
They laid demolition on the bridge.
It's like a dream operation.
And one part of the plot though is that the senior British officer at the camp
that the senior prisoner at the camp,
these name and then in the movie is the tenant Colonel Nicholson.
He takes a true leadership role in building the bridge.
Now think about that.
He's being tasked by the Japanese to build this bridge and instead of
sabotaging the job,
because it's gonna help the Japanese,
he actually gets his Ben fired up and helps organize and has his engineer's
redesign it,
and they relocate it to a better piece of terrain.
And,
and he pushes his men to do a good job building it.
And he actually takes pride in this bridge.
And again,
this is a bridge.
It's going to aid in Japanese,
Japanese domination.
So when the commandos show up to blow it up,
the colonel,
he,
he almost foils the attack,
but at the end the bridge gets destroyed.
It's an awesome movie.
And it was,
like I said,
it was very influential to me as a kid and people should definitely watch it.
And then you should know this.
It's all a lie.
What's the Lli there?
Well,
there really was a bridge on the river Kwai and it really was built by prisoners
of war.
But that's about where
the similarities and what the prisoners suffered at the hands of the imperial
Japanese guards is beyond anything that they showed in the movie.
And really beyond anything that even remotely civilized person could imagine.
I was,
uh,
I was overseas recently in Europe and I was in Britain and a friend of mine gave
me a book called the forgotten Highlander.
And he told me,
you know,
oh,
it's by one of the soldiers that built the bridge on the river.
Kwai read it.
And I thought to myself,
okay,
you know,
great.
It's like the movie.
And he said,
it's not like the movie.
It's not like the movie at all.
And it isn't.
This is a book
that shows the ultimate in human suffering.
And through that,
the ultimate in human will.
The Arthur Allister,
your cart
was fresh to the British military.
He was sent to Singapore.
And when Singapore was overrun by the Japanese imperial army,
he ended up in the jungle,
a prisoner
and a slave.
By this time,
mental health had become a major issue on the railway.
We all suffered from depression.
Men were taking their lives all along the railway.
Men cut their own throats,
put their heads on the railway line,
and simply walked into the jungle to die.
Many develop the a taps stare and just looked intent.
We ever fache roof of the Haute death.
Soon followed.
Others went mad because of medical conditions caused by vitamin decision
deficiencies and some just gave up losing their minds and their self control.
They would fight with anyone over nothing at all,
throwing punches,
biting,
kicking.
They needed to be controlled physically
but just could not be calm down.
It came to a point where something drastic had to be done to prevent innocent
men being killed by terrains to fellow prisoners,
some of whom had reverted to animal instincts.
The decision was made to build our own lunatic asylum to cage these poor souls
with the agreement of the Japanese,
the barrier party built two,
six foot square bamboo cages.
The mad men could stand or lie down in these just 10 feet from my hut and they
had a bench to sit on.
They received food and water,
but sadly,
we're largely ignored at night.
It was awful to hear them in the darkness jabbering in screaming,
throwing themselves at the cages.
The man who went in never came out alive.
Death would have been welcome for them.
It was a dreadful thing to see our fellow human beings caged like animals,
but what else could we do?
You know,
as I was preparing for this in a lot of times when I'm putting notes together,
I'm thinking about some thing that I'm going to say,
some comparable thing that I can bring back from some of my experiences
and I got nothing for you.
I got nothing for you and this,
this book is just like that.
Back to the book.
I turned to God several times,
often I felt my prayers went unanswered,
but I somehow live through this madness and I think that someone must have been
listening,
but faith in God could not prevent the beatings on the railway,
which were totally routine.
The threat of a rifle across your head or bamboo cane across your body forever
loomed large for no reason at all.
Why are whips would lash into our backs and draw blood.
Some guards would creep up on you and strike the open tropical ulcers on your
legs with a bamboo stick causing intense agony.
Often they delivered these beatings with such brutality and swiftness that you
did not see them coming or even know that they were what they were for.
Sometimes you just happen to be in the wrong place at the wrong time.
The Korean guards took a certain pleasure in the beatings.
They had expressed permission to kill prisoners without any reference to higher
authority,
but most of them would be satisfied to stop at the site of a blood trickling.
The beatings,
no matter how frequent,
never got easier to take.
In fact,
they got tougher each time.
I took a beating and chipped away,
not just at my bones and waning muscles,
but at my will to endure them.
The dilemma,
the dilemma was whether to swallow your pride by going down at the first blow or
to retain some of your dignity by taking several blows and standing up to them.
If you,
if you refuse to show that they're blows or hurting you,
they would fly into rages and the beating could be severe,
even fatal
from an early period.
The Japanese camp commandant,
whom I called the black prince,
became ever more inventive with his punishments.
I can not imagine a more sadistic and evil person on the planet.
The more heinous the so called crime,
the sicker the sentence under his instructors.
Under his instructions,
the guards had free reign if they felt you deserved something more than a
beating,
it meant taking you aside and making you pick up a large boulder for the rest of
the day.
You had to hold the rock over your head in the blazing heat.
Within minutes,
you're already weakened.
Malnourished arms would start to twitch and fail you.
Before long,
you would have to drop the rock,
usually the size of a rugby ball or football mindful so that you did so without
letting it fall on your own skull.
When you let go,
the guards would pounce fists,
rifle butts and boots flailing into your body until you picked up the rock
again.
It would go on all day and if the Japanese officer did not think you had learned
your lesson sufficiently,
the punishment would be replete repeated.
Back at camp,
the black prince was a true bastard.
Others called him the can you kid?
But I thought my name is suited lieutenant.
Ooh,
Suki really?
Well.
He was darker than the other Japanese soldiers and strutted around like royalty
is beefy gut protruding from beneath a shabby uniform.
He despised us totally.
We were scum to him.
His absolute power over us and capacity for pity lessness per pitiless brutality
made him so terrifying to me.
Okay.
Long before our decision to incarcerate crazy men,
the Japanese had built their own cages.
The black holes,
as they were known were a higher form of punishment.
Those fortunate enough to be locked inside the those unfortunate enough to be
locked inside the sem,
the semi subterranean cages proportion so you could not stand,
lie down or even Neil Foley would be kept in for a month.
Typically corrugated iron and metal covered the bamboo to intensify the heat and
deprive victims of air and any cooling breeze.
Few who went in came out alive.
Yeah,
it's
okay.
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
The black prince,
his right hand man was sergeant Cici,
known to US Brits simply as doctor death,
short and squat.
He took the roll calls and carried out all of the camp commandants orders.
Presumably he was more educated than the other Japanese or Koreans,
but he was evil to the marrow.
Ruthless in the extreme.
He loved tormenting us.
He especially reveled in a sickening brand of water torture.
He had guards pin down his hapless victim before pouring gallons of water down
the prisoners throat using a bucket and a hose.
The man's stomach would swell up from huge volumes of water.
Yeah.
He would then jump up and down gleefully on the prisoners stomach.
Sometimes the guards tied barbed wire around the poor soul.
Stomach.
Few survived
when a prisoner was caught stealing from the Japanese officers,
storeroom,
or if a man turned on a guard,
they received the next grade on the sliding scale of Japanese torture.
I called it the Indian rope trick,
one favored by Indians in the old cowboy films.
The helpless prisoners would be tethered,
spread eagle to the ground.
They wrapped wet rat,
the same string like bark used to lash are bamboo huts together around his
ankles and wrists and tied him to stakes in the ground.
As the return dried,
the ties would slowly gas into the skin drawing blood and tearing into the sinew
and cartilage as it pulled limbs from their sockets.
It reduced even the toughest men to agonize,
screaming,
and they would be there all day.
I would almost be glad to get out of camp in the mornings just to avoid hearing
their cries of unbridled pain.
It was a way of torturing all of us.
Often when returned from a day on the railway,
the men would no longer be there.
Nobody asked where they advantage too.
I certainly did not want to know after such a horrific ordeal at the end of a
Japanese bay,
Annette would have been welcomed.
So as time went on,
eventually know when they showed up,
they had their,
their pants,
their shirt,
their boots,
their socks,
and as time went on de Paul,
that stuff just got destroyed to got eaten by the jungle as they worked and
eventually fell apart
and one of the worst things to lose is the last thing that Alastar lost was his
boots.
Okay.
Now in bare feet,
I had a new challenge.
My feet were extremely soft from living constantly in wet boots and the ground
was particularly unforgiving.
The jagged volcanic rocks off and hiding just below the surface of topsoil.
I knew that the soles would harden up,
but until then I would have to walk like a cripple.
When using the speed,
I wouldn't be able to use my foot to dig deeper into the soil and would have and
would require more upper body strength.
Having no boots also made the ever frequent trips to the Bengals,
the latrines even more unsavory.
They were revolting,
vast open pits.
Later covered in after we can.
Prisoners began to collapse into them and drown.
As you approached the Benyus,
you had to wade through the mud layered with excrement of those disencouraged
sufferers who never quite made it.
Flies and maggots and flies and maggots swarmed.
And over this foul mush,
it got so bad that we had a bucket of water at the entrance to wash our hut to
wash our feet in it all added to the misery.
It's amazing what we take for granted,
isn't it?
Yeah,
to say the least.
And he goes on to talk about,
and if you,
if you,
how do you deal with this when you're going through it and he writes in moments
of adversity,
I would often think back to my childhood and remember going barefoot during the
long hot summers we spent down at the Aberdeen,
Aberdeen,
sure.
Fisher fishing village of Newton Hill where I was born.
So there is,
you know,
having to go barefoot.
His feet practically falling off and the best thing he can do is try and think
of the good times in his life when he was forced to go barefoot.
And you would think,
you would think some level of comradery would be critical.
And this is one of those books where again,
in almost every military book you hear about leadership and comradery and
there's points in this book where that stuff fails,
fails,
and this is where he kind of talks about that.
Back to the book,
I even castigated myself for getting involved with another prisoners problems.
Once you got started with sentimentality in grief,
you were a goner.
It was a selfish tactic,
but I was desperate to survive.
I was refusing to let the Japanese when this,
like on the death march,
some men found the going easier by teaming up and making a close bond with
another prisoner.
They would fight railway life together,
sharing whatever food they had,
helping each other wherever they could,
and always having their back.
They even took beatings together to share the blows and the pain.
It was not the way for me.
I watched the heartache of men losing their best pals and suddenly being left
alone.
They never leave.
They never usually lasted very long and soon followed their mates to their
grave.
By
now.
The cuts on my feet and legs had turned into painful and dangerous tropical
ulcers.
When I suffered scrapes on the railway or had a rash,
I could not tend to it until yes sumi time,
which is like rest time or he's time or until I was back at camp.
Then I wrap leaves around the cuts at night to keep the flies off,
but it was a useless and the ulcers usually spread.
They routed your flesh muscle and tendons.
People were left with gaping holes as the flesh simply fell away and also would
eat deep into your flesh so deep you could sometimes see the white of bone even
worse if you are not careful,
they can become gangrenous and many men lost legs that way.
By improvised amputation without anesthetics or drugs.
I went to the medical hut for advice in common with most of the men.
Tropical ulcers had engulfed my feet,
ankles,
and lower calves.
I had avoided the medical hot until that point.
It was set aside from the sleeping hots and about the same size as ours.
The officer in charge was Dr Mathew Mathewson,
a likable character from Paisley,
just outside Glasgow where he had studied medicine.
He had come to Singapore about the same time as me and would later in much
different circumstances saved my life on this.
My first encounter with him,
he would at least save my legs
sneaking under the cloud of black flies that circled outside the hut like a
swarm of miniature vultures.
I entered nervously.
The overpowering stench immediately had me gasping,
stepping across the cadavers forms of five or six men who appeared to be rapping
at death's door.
Dr Mathewson introduced himself.
I had not spoken for so many days that when I went to reply,
my parched throat failed me here.
He said,
handing me a half coconut cup of water.
Get this down you.
I sipped the cool water down and thanked him asking how his patients were.
Doctor Matthia centered,
his mid thirties at this point appeared weary beyond his years.
He,
he was probably on self imposed half rations just to keep some spare for his
patients.
The men.
It's spoke highly of him and many of our docs doctors were revered as saintly
figures.
The doctor took me by the arm and led me down to the far end of the hut away
from the men in a soft west coast accent.
He said,
half of these men will die within days.
The other half,
who knows if I had access to some proper clinical treatments,
drugs are instruments they might live,
but that is not possible.
As I'm sure you know,
I can only nod in agreement.
The squalor and stench of death inside the hut was appalling.
What can you do for them?
I asked quite simply,
not a lot.
I try and give them some hope.
If nothing else,
he went on.
It's easy for these men to give up and when they lose hope,
the fight just seems to seep right out of them.
On countless occasions,
I've seen two men with the same symptoms and the same physical state and one
will die and one will make it.
I can only put that down to sheer willpower.
We do talk about willpower.
Yeah.
I don't think we've ever discussed a willpower at this level,
and that is when you have two men with the same symptoms of the same physical
state in one dies and one lives,
and the doctor's only determination as he thinks it comes down to sheer
willpower,
but will is strong.
Who's the strong force?
I considered this for a moment and looked around the hut.
You could tell the man who were dying by the look on their faces.
Their gaze was lost before it reached their eyes,
and no amount of positive attitude care for Dr Mathewson could change their
destiny.
It certainly was not the medical staff's fault.
Their hands were tied.
No blood was firmly on our captors hands.
I told myself right then and there that I would not stop fighting.
What can you do for this?
I asked the doctor,
lifting a foot onto a bamboo cheer,
tropical ice,
tropical ulcers,
a disease of food,
filth,
and friction.
Do you know what maggots looked like?
Maggots,
I asked frantically inspecting my foot,
praying that I was subject to some sick joke.
Yes,
maggots,
they'll fix you right up.
Go down to the latrines,
find yourself a handful of those we white beasties and set them on your ulcers.
They will chomp through the dead flesh.
Before you know it,
you'll be right as rain almost as an afterthought.
He added.
Remember to count how many you put on carefully.
You don't want to forget one and leaving it there to eat itself to death.
I left the medical whole hut shaking my head,
still wondering if I were being had letting maggots eat.
My skin did not sound particularly appetizing,
but I was willing to willing to try anything I knew I had to stop the rot that
was devouring my legs.
The latrines were nothing more than holes in the ground,
but now with bamboo slats across them,
a bunch of jungle leaves usually laid pile near or you took your own foliage or
toilet paper.
If there was no river water collected for the job.
I did not have to go far to find what I was looking for.
I gingerly scooped up a handful of maggots watching them squirm and wriggle
without thinking about it too much.
I found a quiet spot nearby and sat down placing just two or three out of nasty
ulcer on my ankle.
The maggots,
which were about a quarter of an inch long,
instinctively knew what to do.
They started gnawing away at my skin in the most with the most minuscule of
bites.
The sensation was of tingling.
Unearthly yet not altogether unpleasant until the realization that the maggots
were eating your raw flesh came racing back to the forefront of your mind.
I can still feel that sensation to this day,
but to Dr Mathewson's credit,
it certainly worked within days.
The wounds,
it started to heal and nu skin grew back.
It was a trick that I persisted with throughout my time on the railway,
passing it on to other men when I thought I could.
Okay.
They still use that today,
by the way.
The maggots thing.
Yeah.
Um,
well I've heard of it.
That's crazy how he was kinda like,
um,
like,
you know,
I'll never forget that feeling of the maggots,
but he,
he talked about it as not being totally unpleasant.
Kinda liked it.
Okay.
Probably because he knew it was kind of healing them,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's heavy breathers heavy.
Yeah,
so now we get into a guy that had tried to escape,
was captured.
I was unaware that anyone had escaped until one morning.
A sorry looking chap was dragged before us.
He had been horrifically beaten,
is swollen and bloody features,
virtually unrecognizable.
The interpreter told us this man very bad.
He tried to escape.
No good.
Two guards threw him down to the ground in front of us,
the battery wreck of a human frame and made him kneel.
He did not plead for mercy or beg for assistance.
He knew his fate and waited.
Silently resigned to it.
The black prince who seem to have dressed up,
especially for the occasion,
strode forward and unsheathed his long Samurai's sword.
He prodded the prisoner in the back,
forcing him to straighten up.
Okay.
Then the black prince raised his sword.
It stainless deal glinted in the sunshine.
It was a moment of such horror that I could scarcely believe it was really
happening.
I closed my eyes tightly.
This was one of the many instances of barbarism on the railway that I would try
to shut out of my mind,
but I could not escape the chilling swash of the blade as it cut through the
damp tropical air or the sickening flack of the sword coming down on our
comrades neck,
followed by the Dole thump of his head,
landing on the ground.
I kept my eyes firmly shut,
but suede on my feet and felt a collective gasp of impotence,
anger,
and revulsion.
And that line right there
is
something that when I heard it and when I read it,
I kind of thought to myself that this is what separates every experience I've
had in my life with this.
And that is this,
this gasp of impotent anger and revulsion.
So the angers there,
the revulsion is there,
but it's impotent and you can't do anything about it because you're a slave and
you're at the mercy of another human being.
Your freedom has been taken away.
And I talk about freedom
fairly often
and I don't think there could be any greater reminder of how precious freedom is
been reading about someone.
About a group of men that have had their freedom completely taken from them.
Now,
at this point in the book,
and I wanted to point this out because if you have seen the movie,
the bridge on the river Kwai,
he makes some,
he kind of spells out the differences.
The building of the bridge on the river Kwai took a terrible toll on us and the
depiction of our sufferings in the film of the same name was a very,
very sanitized version of the events.
Unlike the welfare add extras in the movie,
we did not whistle colonel bogey tune,
nor did we work alongside Americans,
nor do we have any semblance of a uniform.
We were naked,
barefoot slaves,
and there were certainly no pretty and scantily clad local girls wandering
through the jungle and contrary to the film are real life commander.
Colonel Philip Tuesday did not collaborate with the Japanese.
I was not alone in doing as little work as possible without blatantly shirking,
which resulted in sadistic beatings,
energy.
Every ounce of it had to be conserved for survival.
To bust a gut on starvation rations was absolute suicide.
We had long lost our dignity and working faster certainly would not have brought
it back.
In fact,
it would have resulted in us in the opposite,
would even more of us dying.
Instead,
we made constant attempts to sabotage med whispered orders to impair the
construction of the bridge wherever possible.
Some charged with making up concrete mixtures deliberately added too much sand
or not enough,
which would later have disastrous effects.
We collected a huge numbers of termites in white ants and deposited them into
grooves and joints of load bearing trucks
out of sight of guards.
I,
I saw it halfway through.
Wouldn't bolts wherever possible,
hoping they would snap whenever any serious weight like a train was placed upon
them.
But the river Kwai and its tributaries harbored a killer even more lethal than
the Japanese and our starvation diet
as an inevitable consequence of the lack of sanitation and the tens of thousands
of bodies buried in shallow graves are dumped along in the jungle.
The river system was loaded with cholera bacteria and the monsoon season became
Colorado season
as the heightened waters of the [inaudible] of the quiet flushed Vibrio chlorine
Culinaria
throughout the land.
This fearful disease cast a black shadow over the camp collar arrived unseen and
unheard,
but soon had us in its grip.
I was slow to hear about it,
but I sent something terrible was in the camp.
More men were falling ill than usual and the Japanese kept their distance
leaving us alone.
They were scared to death of catching cholera themselves.
So this wretched disease comes into camp and you just don't think things can get
worse and they do
okay
and you think that Allister's get or avoid cholera,
but he doesn't.
Overnight cholera struck me down.
I woke up with explosive diarrhea and violent projectile vomiting.
My ears were ringing as I felt dizzy.
Cramps started in my bowels and soon spread all over my body as it rapid be
dehydrated.
I was drying from the inside out,
shriveling like a picked grape left out in the sun,
the cholera bacteria burden to the walls of my small intestine producing toxins.
That sucked my vinyl salts and every ounce of water out of my body.
I was unsure what was wrong,
but I knew this,
but I knew it was serious.
I did not want to finish up with life drained out of me.
I had always been extremely careful to drink only boiled water,
so at first I was doubtful that it was cholera.
I did not know much about it,
but I knew that the first 24 hours were crucial.
If you see through a day in a night,
you would probably survive most men who succumbed did so in the first few hours,
a horrible death and so quick men who threw the bodies of cholera victims onto
the few funeral pyres in the morning could easily contract the disease,
die and be thrown on the pyre themselves.
That evening they died in agony like crazed animals and it was dreadful to see.
I lay in my bed unable to rise for Work Party by that I was semiconscious and I
thought it was the end.
I was hallucinating,
vivid red flashes,
stormed my eyelids.
I knew I had to seek help after psyching myself up on.
I managed to rise and wobble to doc doctor Mathewson's hut.
As soon as I walked in,
he knew that I had cholera.
It was a death sentence and he was reluctant to tell me.
Instead,
he looked at me and simply said,
you'll have to be isolated.
You'll be looked after.
His orderlies led me to a cream colored tint like the ones we had used in the
scouts.
As they peel back the tents front flap,
a deathly leaped out unknown to me.
This was the death tent and I was the unlucky 13th occupant of a dimly lit space
already full of men.
When I saw their state,
their eyes rolling back rasping unintelligible voices,
their legs raised with knees bent.
The bizarre telltale sign of a cholera,
a sufferer.
I knew that my number was up.
The orderlies were putting me here to die.
The fight was feeding from me and I laid down on the canvas floor with a sense
of complete and utter desolation,
but he did survive.
Out of the 13 men that wind to the tent.
He was the only survivor
now.
Yeah.
At this point in the book,
and I want you to remember that this isn't a book.
This is another human being,
his life and at this point in Allister's life,
he actually got moved to
a nother facility,
another prison camp that was for people that weren't really bad,
bad shape.
Yeah.
And he was there.
He went through some recovery time and that's a very important part of the book.
And then he begins working on the docks,
you know,
unloading food stores for the Japanese soldiers and loading them.
And eventually it comes time for him to be moved.
And so they move the prisoners of war by shipping them
on four September,
1944 900 British POW is,
we're rushed up the gangway of the Cotcha Dokie Maru,
a 10,000 ton cargo vessel that had been named for,
that have been named the President Harrison before it was captured from the
Americans using sticks.
The Japanese drove us like cattle aboard the ship and down into the holds.
We can never move fast enough for them.
The liner had two holds,
both quite obviously not made to accommodate human beings yet.
They wanted around 450 of us in each.
The lads below were shouting,
begging,
and pleading for the Japanese not to let any more men,
but the louder they shouted,
the more frenzied the gars became down and down.
We went into the depths of hell.
Nothing in all of our suffering had prepared me for anything like this and even
today I can scarcely find the words to describe the horrors of the catch.
A Doki Maru.
By the time I got down to the hold,
I had nowhere to sit.
It was standing room only.
Most of us packed in like star sardines with no toilet facilities.
Most had dysentery,
malaria,
Barry,
and all manners of tropical diseases.
Once inside and the hold crammed full,
the Japanese battened down the hatches plunging us into a terrifying black Pitt.
At that moment,
the most fearful clamor went up as claustrophobia and panic gripped the men.
Many feared they were doomed and began screaming and shouting.
You had a strange tranquility came over me.
I felt resigned and just thought,
this is it.
I thought that we would never get out alive.
I would never see home again.
You felt resigned to accept this as your last.
I could only think that they were taking us out to sea to sink the ship and
drown us.
All our captors were capable of it.
I had seen what they were capable of.
Anything.
Okay.
We knew nothing about these ships which would become infamous in the annals of
the Second World War history as hell ships a fleet of dozens of rusting hoax
used to shuttle supplies and prisoners around Japan's far eastern empire.
Some of the most appalling episodes.
The war occurred on these ships in which men driven crazy by thirst,
killed fellow prisoners to drink their blood.
In some cases,
prisoners trying to escape from the CV.
Massive hysterical captives were shot by Japanese soldiers.
Some voyages took weeks with only a handful of prisoners surviving.
Men drink their own urine.
Sick prisoners were trampled to death or suffocated.
The sane murdered the insane and wondered when it would be their turn to go mad
cannibalism as well as vampirism was not unknown and even Japanese medics were
shocked by what they found when the holds were finally opened.
In the case of the Oroco Maru were insane prisoners killed fellow man for their
blood.
Only 271 men survived out of 1,619
so all those times that you think of horror movies and they don't seem realistic
and you don't think it could ever happen,
it has happened.
There must have been at least one officer,
a warrant officer or a sergeant major somewhere in the hold,
but they certainly didn't make themselves known.
Discipline had gone,
everyone,
whatever their rank was in the same situation.
All of us just wanted to survive and we're prepared to do anything to ensure
that happened.
It would have taken a very brave man to try and take command of the men in the
hold and these conditions,
it would have been suicidal
eight.
Again,
that's one of those points where,
you know every book we've talked about,
no matter how bad things get,
there's a leader ready to step up.
Then you wonder if there's a line that you could ever go across where that
doesn't happen.
Well,
here it is.
Okay.
I thought,
I never thought anything could ever match.
The terror of the railway being in the hold was worse.
At least slaving on the railway.
You could move and you had fresh air.
Then another dread thought struck me,
submarines,
the catchy Docu Maru had no Red Cross markings painted on it.
I would later learn that,
that none of the hell ships bore any indication that [inaudible] we're on board
as they were required to do by Geneva Convention.
Red Crosses were however painted on Japanese ammunition carriers.
My fears that without markings,
we were a target for our own side.
So he starts thinking,
well,
um,
we're part of the Japanese fleet.
Now.
What if we get attacked by our own people?
What if we get sunk
and as you can probably foresee,
because this story is just a misery upon misery.
It happens
in the hold of the Catcher,
Doki Maru,
the tournament went on,
the noise was constant and deafening and awful.
Cacophony of throbbing engines,
moaning,
coughing and occasional panic stricken,
screaming the background music for this latest torture.
The chilling screams of the mad and insane would stop abruptly.
I don't know how they were dealt with,
but I could imagine
I was completely stuck where I was in the hole and could not move.
No one could.
You couldn't sit or lie.
You couldn't even go down to your haunches.
There was so little room you didn't really want to lie down anyway.
It was a sea of human waste and you rest being trampled.
You had your space and protected it with your life.
Quite literally.
You stayed strong protecting your space with elbows and fists by any means
necessary.
By this stage,
it was every man for himself.
Each person had their own problems to resolve their own life to save.
Again,
we have not seen this yet.
Every man for himself.
Yeah.
The smell inside the hold was indescribable or a pug.
Stench and overpowering mixture of excrement,
urine vomit,
sweaty bodies,
weeping,
all servers and rotting flesh clock.
The atmosphere.
There was no way we could get any fresh air.
Even when the Japanese open the hatches,
it really didn't help that much.
You are still breathing in what was already there
first became our biggest problem.
People don't understand what real thirst truly is.
You start to hallucinate and see Mirages and that is the most dangerous thing.
People died down in the holes from suffocation or heart attacks.
The men who died were not taking away their bodies lay among us.
So one of the other vessels,
okay,
that they're out with gets hit with a torpedo.
American torpedo.
It's another vessel that's holding prisoners of war.
It is the
1,317 were killed.
Yeah.
Or sorry,
1,317 prisoners were on board.
None of them were killed by the explosion,
but 1,159 of them ground or died of exposure.
And
mind you.
These were all guys that had served on the death of rail way.
Guys that had already suffered just unimaginable torture
and then as he suspected,
it became their turn.
Okay.
Four minutes later,
we suddenly felt a tremendous blast and an explosion tore through the hold.
The whole structure shuttered and water flooded in it from above.
I knew then as the water crashed on top of me that my worst fears had been
realized.
We'd been hit and I knew that the torpedo had struck very close to us.
It was in fact the first of two torpedoes that would send the hell ship to the
bottom.
Within 15 minutes,
the ship tilted.
We were going down
so the ship sinks.
Now the Japanese said immediately tried to get off with lifeboats.
It left all the prisoners trying to just create rafts with whatever they could.
Even after the sinking,
the killing went on.
For those of us who survived and got onto rafts,
anyone starting to panic was thrown off into the sea.
When they scrambled to get back,
they were kicked away.
Men pushed under and held.
The Japanese men pushed under an held under Japanese survivors fighting broke
out as the animal instinct to survive asserted itself,
making some survivors try to capture more seaworthy vessels and shove others off
to their deaths.
Many gave up already,
so weak,
dangerously dehydrated and ill.
Many golf,
salt water and quickly went stark raving mad,
drowning themselves to end the torment.
Horrible as it may sound.
As men became mad,
they had to be shoved off of the rafts or boats or the remainder might've parish
perished.
Okay.
There was a lot of shouting and screaming,
cries of,
get off you bastard or I'll kill you.
Made me close my eyes and distress.
Most of the shouts or English,
there were not many Japanese,
the majority of whom had gotten off early in the lifeboats,
drowning and dying.
Men called for their wives,
their children or mothers.
Men said things like,
daddy will be home soon and then disappeared beneath the waves.
It was horrifying to here.
By that stage,
most of us,
we're treading a very fine line between sanity and madness.
It didn't take much to put people over the top.
I couldn't see where it's coming from.
But a group of men started singing first to keep their spirits up.
They sang rule Britannia
after the seller rang a incident.
We had been banned from singing this stirring anthem with its line about
Britain's never ever being slaves.
So there you start seeing some spirit.
Yeah.
As they start singing rule Britannia now cellaring incident was when some
prisoners,
it just,
just when a Japanese taken over and Singapore and the light,
and I forgive me if I don't remember this correctly,
but a couple of guys that tried to escape and they got caught and basically it
was a standoff between the,
the soldiers and the Japanese prisoners are Japanese prison camp commanders.
And they wouldn't end the,
the soldiers did not back down until they had executed for,
uh,
the four prisoners that had tried to escape.
And then they kept everyone else locked in this compound for five days.
And when the guys started to die from starvation and dysentery and dehydration
than they,
they said,
okay,
we'll spend,
they signed a paper that said no one else would try to escape,
but they,
they held the line as long as they possibly could.
Hmm.
244 of my comrades on there catch a Doki Maru died that night.
It was tragic beyond belief that having survived the death railway,
they became prisoners of the deep
1,403 allied servicemen had died as a result of the failure of the Japanese to
observe the Geneva Convention and apply Red Crosses to our hell ships.
He ends up getting recaptured by the Japanese after the,
after the ships.
Yes,
he does survive.
He gets recaptured by the Japanese.
Eventually he's close to where Nagasaki is,
but far enough away that he doesn't die from the blast of Nagasaki.
The war ends.
They get picked up and eventually they're
obviously brought home by Americans and eventually sent back to England.
He says that when he left Aberdeen,
he'd Wade healthy hundred and 35 pounds,
but here in Nagasaki on the steel yard scales,
very act accurate contraptions.
Similar to those I'd used at the plumbers merchants,
I was reduced,
reduced to a skeletal 82 pounds.
Okay.
I've got some pictures of these guys.
I mean they literally look like skeletons.
It's,
it's,
it's unbelievable that they were even able to survive
new arrivals.
Men from the vast industrial gulag.
The Japanese had created in Phuket an hour flooded the quayside and lengthen the
cues for showers.
So they're basically cleaning these guys up now,
getting ready to put them on ships and ship them back to America.
Sadly,
at this final hurdle,
some did not make it and died on Quaye this distressed the Americans immensely
and they were shocked by the matter of fact way that the other prisoners
accepted the deaths of their mates.
We had seen so much
too much.
Now
I think quite possibly this is the
heaviest book that we've talked about
on the podcast.
Yeah,
I would agree with that.
And it's one of those things where
it's a question if people
are even going to want to listen to this,
and I understand that.
I understand that some people did not make it through this reading
and some people
listened to it.
Some people are gonna buy this bulk of which they should,
and some people are going to take this
as a
message
from somebody who has seen evil
in a way that not too many people can claim to have seen
in a person that has had their every freedom taken from them and their lives and
their destiny
put into the hands of sadistic people.
Now,
if you did make it this far,
I will
let this end
on a,
on an incredibly,
incredibly
positive note and message
from the author
and he says this,
my time is a prisoner of the Japanese helped shape and determine my path in life
just as much as my childhood did.
Like it or not.
The horrors did happen to me and to thousands of others.
Yet some good has come out of it.
My ordeal has made me a much more patient,
caring person inspired by the devotion of our hard pressed medics on the death
rail way.
I was able to care for my young daughter when she was ill and from my late wife
who required 24 hour attention in the last stages of her life while in Japan and
working with my friend Dr Mathewson,
I vowed to spend the rest of my life helping others and I'm so pleased to say
that I have done so.
It is where my satisfaction comes from nowadays.
Okay.
I have tried to use my experiences in a positive fashion and have adopted a
motto from them,
which I never tire of telling others.
There is no such word as can't.
I have not allowed my life to be blighted by bitterness at 90 years of age.
I've lived a long life and continue to live it to the fullest.
I enjoyed a long marriage to my wife and I have been fortunate to have a family
and to enjoy their success.
I've amazed my doctors,
my friends,
my family,
and myself by remaining fit.
I am grateful for my present way of life.
After all the turmoil that life has thrown at me and thankful to have retained
my sense of humor.
Most importantly,
I now visit schools to tell pupils what really happened in the Far East during
those term terrible warriors and my 91st year.
I am fortunate enough,
despite the best efforts of the Japanese imperial army,
to have the vim and vigor required to tell a new generation of how we suffered
scandalously our sufferings,
which of haunted all of us Far East prisoners of war throughout our lives.
We're only recognized by the British government in the year 2000 when it offered
compensation of 10,000 pounds to remaining survivors.
Unbelievably,
the British taxpayer had to pay out that poultry sum and not the culpable
Japanese government.
I hope this book will stand as an indictment of the criminal regime that ran
Japan during the war years and the failure of successive Japanese governments to
face up to their crimes.
But I hope too that it will be inspirational and offer hope to those who
suffered adversity in their daily lives,
especially in these difficult times.
Life is worth living
no matter what it throws at you.
Is it important to keep your eyes on the prize of that happiness will come
even when the death rail way reduced us to little more than animals,
humanity and the shape of our st we medical officer's triumphed over barbarism.
Remember,
while it seemed,
while it always seems darkest before the dawn,
perseverance pays off and the good times will return.
May Health and happiness be yours,
Allister Urquhart
July,
life is worth living.
Geez.
Yeah,
the book is the forgotten Highlander.
It is a phenomenal read.
It is a reality check.
It is
incredibly moving
and I highly recommend you buy it.
You read it,
okay.
And you understand what the world is.
You get a better understanding of what the world is about.
And I know I definitely got a better understanding of what the world is about in
reading this.
Okay.
We're pretty much every detail,
like every,
every little element that he went through made me think like,
Dang,
I'd rather,
I'd probably rather die in that situation.
I know every little thing that happened.
Yeah.
And there's,
uh,
there's obviously thousands and thousands and thousands of men that made that
choice.
Yeah.
And there will got broken and they just,
they lost the will to live.
So it's incredible how strong the human will is that you can survive that e two
pounds distri starvation ulcers in your legs,
putting magnets on your legs.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's just,
um,
it's truly incredible what the,
what the human can survive.
And it's also truly incredible what the human can complain about in this day and
age.
Right.
I mean,
we can complain about just the most ridiculous things.
Yeah.
Just the most ridiculous things.
It's crazy.
He'll help pig that spectrum is,
yeah.
Just remind me to never complain about anything ever again.
You know what I mean?
Don't,
don't let me complain
about anything ever again.
I mean,
I don't consider myself a big complainer,
but come on,
this is just,
we have no reason to complain about anything.
Yeah,
yeah.
Men,
what's crazy too is one of one of the heavier parts there where I felt it was
when he talked about the claustrophobia heart.
Yeah.
I know you have an issue with it.
Bang.
It's there,
but it's not,
it's not,
I'm not super sensitive to it,
but it's something I know.
I feel that,
that,
that's like a tough one to get over it,
you know?
Yeah.
Dang.
And especially going through all that stuff first and then you got to deal with,
I dunno,
man,
this might be too heavy for me.
Well,
it was too heavy for a lot of people
and yeah,
I mean it's almost like
we almost don't need to have a discussion about this book.
You know,
meg just,
just stop talking about it.
Everyone go read it.
I get it.
You know?
And just,
let's move on,
you know,
because like I said,
it just makes you realize
just what kind of suffering there can be and how good you've got it.
How good you've got it.
I'm going to go to bed tonight in my bed and it's going to feel good.
You you're good to appreciate that I'm appreciated every night.
Yup.
Yeah,
so cause you think about like some little things you don't even think about,
but they're like a real luxury.
It's just things that you really enjoy but you don't even think about it.
They're just,
they're just like a whatever.
Like for me,
I really like a nice cold,
you know,
big a bottle of water.
You know,
I have a big,
just a big bottle of water.
I completely take it for granted.
When I go to workout in the morning,
I dropped a couple of ice cubes in there and fill it up.
It's all nice filtered and whatnot.
Oh I don't think anything about that.
That would be like Heaven,
heaven.
And then you get,
do you know you go to bed at night,
you just crawl into the,
to the the 500 thread sheets or I don't know.
There's some,
there's some kind of sheets that are nice,
but whatever.
They are some kind of cotton sheets that are all nice.
Yeah.
You climb into those,
you don't think about that.
You're not thankful for that every night.
Yeah,
pretty much everything,
pretty much.
It pretty much everything.
Even like how you know how you're breathing right now,
consider that compared to that.
What you just read there?
Just,
well just breathing.
Listening.
She started with that.
Let's just break it down with air.
Yay.
The beginning.
And I remember,
um,
the cable guy was coming,
which already sounds silly.
I know.
And I'm,
and he was late.
He was supposed to come to,
was the cutoff,
right where he was going to call.
It was like,
you know,
before the struggle is real.
The cable guy was late.
Yeah.
So he can't,
I dunno,
two 15 or something and I had to go,
I want to see it go to workout or something.
This is getting worse and worse.
I know this,
the point is get a bt.
Yeah.
For my 15 minutes later he's,
you know,
he's,
he's fixing that fixing thing.
Yeah.
And,
yeah,
and that's one of the things I thought of primarily when you said think of all
the little luxuries.
So not only,
not only am I complaining
about something I don't need,
I'm complaining about something that I'm kidding,
like supreme luxury.
I'm complaining about that,
you know,
because it didn't come 15 minutes of all things,
um,
before the time that it did.
Yeah.
I'm gonna check myself to good idea.
I'm going to check myself too.
So with that,
what's,
uh,
go to some questions
from the Internet
and actually to start this one off,
um,
after the last podcast,
number 11,
when I had lay fon and we talked about mark,
we talked about Mark Lee,
we talked about Ryan,
Joe,
we talked about Chris Kyle,
and you know,
we actually didn't talk about Mikey Monster.
So
I had a couple of people ask me,
hey,
why don't you guys talk about Mikey mountain store?
Well,
the,
the simple reason is it's kind of similar to the reason why I hadn't talked
about mark and Ryan and Chris yet either until I got laid off on,
because leaf was the,
the Charlie platoon commander.
Those guys were in Charlie platoon.
And you know,
I wanted to have him on as a,
you know,
as,
as a,
I don't know what the word I'm looking for is,
but I wanted to have guide from his platoon on or from their platoon on to talk
about them.
And I just,
that's the way I felt.
And so that's what I stuck with with Mikey.
Mikey was in Delta platoon and I can promise you,
I will be talking about Mikey at some point on this.
Mike.
He was just
phenomenal and a hero and a saint.
And
I will actually absolutely be covering his life and how he died and how we
remembered him then,
how we remember him still.
But I,
I really just want to get,
you know,
somebody,
his platoon that was,
you know,
right with him,
uh,
the whole time.
And that's just,
this is the way I feel about it.
So that's what I'm going to do.
And
yeah,
so that's what gonna do with Mikey.
So it was Mikey.
Mikey will definitely,
we know we'll have a show for Mikey.
Absolutely.
Mikey deserves a hell of a show.
Uh,
and we will have it for Mikey.
So be ready for that.
I don't know whom to get.
A lot of the,
a lot of guys from Delta two that are still on active duty,
uh,
the platoon commander still on active duty,
the,
uh,
all his good friends are still on active duty.
So it's going to be tough.
It's going to be tougher.
It might take a little bit of time,
but that's the plan and it'll be worth it.
So let's go to the next question,
Jackal.
Regarding mistakes.
What are some of your own,
in some you've seen made by leaders you've looked up to and how to recover?
Can someone ever fully regained trust?
This is actually a pretty easy one because,
um,
look,
if you make a mistake,
own it.
Uh,
the,
the worst thing you can do if you make a mistake is
trying to avoid taking blame for it.
That's the worst thing you can do.
And if you think about the bosses that you've had,
did you have some boss that made a mistake?
And he's like,
no,
it wasn't my fault.
You just totally lose respect for him.
So you can't do that.
You got to take,
you got to take ownership of it.
Um,
it cause any,
again,
if you think about the bosses that you've had and the Times that you had a boss
that made excuses,
you don't have any mercy on them,
you're just ruthless on them,
you just pick them apart.
So that's step number one is,
um,
you know,
take ownership if you make a mistake.
And that's how it's always seemed to me from,
as I looked up the chain of command,
you know,
if I saw a guy that made mistakes and then he took ownership and we were like,
okay,
cool,
the guys,
you know,
he knows he made a mistake.
Oh well we'll support them if they're doing the other thing and they're blaming
everybody else,
they're not taking ownership.
You're going to have a hard time with that.
And as a matter of fact,
I actually had a mutiny in,
in one of my platoons where this was a long time ago.
It's,
you know,
all the names are long since forgotten,
but we had a,
we had a,
a mutiny in our platoon where we said,
you know,
pretty much on us,
US lower enlisted guys.
We had a,
we went to the,
we literally went to the commanding officer and say,
we don't work with this guy.
Yeah.
So you know,
all these ideas that people have of the military and have,
you know,
we obey orders and all this stuff.
I mean,
think of what a little jackass I was.
We,
you know,
we say,
well,
you know what?
We don't want to reface guy.
We're going to go to the commanding officer and tell him we don't want to work
for this guy.
And a commanding officer.
To his full credit,
he was like,
listen guys,
you can't have a mutiny.
Not at my command.
Not at my team.
You guys suck it up.
You figured out a way to work it out.
Go do what you're told.
Get in line.
Oh,
so the mutiny didn't work and then he fired the guy.
Yeah,
no one he liked basically made it perfectly clear like this is your one chance.
And he fired him.
But it was,
it was,
it was pretty crazy to see,
to see it happen.
But,
and I say this all the time,
it wasn't because the guy lacked tactical scale.
It wasn't because he was physically fit.
Most of the reason was because he just couldn't take anyone's,
you know,
advice.
He wouldn't listen to anybody.
And so when he was making a mistake,
it was like,
no,
we'll do it this way.
No,
it's okay.
Constant cover up for himself and obviously it,
it didn't work out for him.
So you're mutiny sorta just put him on,
put him on notice.
That was his write up essentially.
Yeah.
But I think the commanding officer I think was really just doing the right
thing.
Saying,
look guys,
you can't have a mutiny.
Doesn't work that way.
This is the military.
Get back in there,
do what you're supposed to do.
And then he was like,
okay,
I've got to fire this guy.
Must not be good to have every enlisted guy in the platoon come forward and say,
I don't want to work with this guy.
That's not a good sign.
So the commanding officer did an outstanding job and he was actually a great,
great commanding officer too.
So it kind of worked on the DL.
It worked on the DL,
I guess as an echo would say.
And then I actually,
the guy that took over was one of the best guys I ever worked for it,
if not the best.
Dang.
Yeah,
it was pretty awesome.
Um,
and then as far as regaining trust,
which is the other part of the question,
it's almost as soon as you admit that you made a mistake,
you are automatically regaining trust.
That's where you start regaining trust and it just goes from there.
Then you follow through with what you say.
You know,
you're constantly trying to build trust and relationships.
That's what you're trying to do.
And the minute you're blinding to people,
how are you building trust?
And if you make a mistake and you say it's not your fault,
then that's a lie.
And everyone knows it.
Yeah.
That,
that fear is,
um,
especially not especially,
but in regards to regaining trust,
so to speak,
uh,
in when someone admits mistakes,
they have that fear that all they're going to think,
I don't know what I'm doing or I don't have a handle on this,
you know,
so doesn't matter.
It's so doesn't matter.
It's so much better to go,
hey guys,
I don't really know how to do this.
Can you show me how to do this?
I'm not sure.
I've never done this before.
Right.
Or Hey,
never,
I've never used this kind of weapon before.
Can you give me an,
an UNDOC on this thing?
Right,
right.
The worst thing you can do is step up to the line with a weapon you've never
used before and not know how to lock and loaded or clearance safe.
And it looked like a total idiot.
Cause then you look like a guy that is too arrogant and too insecure to ask.
Yeah.
It's actually,
it's actually a sign of insecurity if you can't ask when you need some help with
something.
Yeah.
And it's funny how when Pete,
when people were in that position and how can it just,
this is kind of a general thing to know is that you're,
you come off way more transparent than you think.
You know,
people will like,
I dunno,
something just as small as like name dropping.
If you name drop someone right even or you just mentioned this person named but
you're really named dropping even in a small way like people can smell that.
So even like this stuff,
stuff that's a little bit more important where if a leader's insecure about
something I want to make,
like he knows everything but he really does.
Even I do stuff like that.
I know,
but
I hate when I do stuff like that I'm like Oh God.
And it's transparent.
Everyone,
everyone knows it.
And a lot of people brother not in touch with that.
They think that all,
yeah they don't know cause I'm just going to sort of mention it and there's all
these little things that it's just you just reek of and I don't want,
I don't want to put it like that.
I want it.
I'll just say,
like I said,
you're way more transparent than you think.
Yeah.
And transparent in this day and age actually has a positive connotation.
I don't know if you know that,
but people view,
oh,
he's really transparent guy.
You know,
he really just tells you what's going on.
If you're deliberately terms,
you're using it in a negative way so people can see right through your bs and
you're not trying to be transparent.
Right.
There's a big difference there.
And uh,
totally true.
But it is definitely better just to,
you know,
ask and say,
Hey,
I dunno that insecurity that when you don't feel like asking something that's a
little knock at your door that says,
oh,
you're insecure,
you're insecure.
When you're like,
Hey,
you know what?
I don't know how to do this.
Can you?
Can you be a hand with this?
Or I'm stuck on this problem here.
Can you,
can you give me help with us?
Cause I don't know how to do it.
People don't say,
Oh,
this guy's an idiot.
Unless you're doing it every three sentences.
Does that mean means you haven't studied?
Yeah.
Cause you gotta study,
you gotta know your trade,
you got to know your craft.
And if you don't,
you got to learn it.
No,
you've got to break out the books and get on it.
But once you broken out the books and now there's a little bit of stuff that you
still don't understand.
Well guess what?
Just ask the question.
Yeah.
Cause your frontline troops is,
are gonna know more than you.
They should know more than you.
Yeah.
You know this,
it's highly likely that there are no more than you.
I mean I was a radio men for eight years in the seal teams and by the time I was
a lieutenant commander in a troop,
I didn't know as much as those,
you know,
guys knew about all the new radios and stuff.
So I just have to ask a question.
It's no big deal.
Yeah.
If you're secure in your leadership,
you're,
you're fine to ask a couple of questions.
It's not that big of a deal,
but you are not clear to lie to people.
You're not clear to make excuses.
And that's what,
that's how you regained the trust is by telling people the truth.
It's really a simple concept,
you know.
Next question
in regards to working out and training for,
um,
you know,
selection.
And by selection you mean,
I mean special forces or ranger or seal selection,
that's what they're talking about here.
Yeah.
So Jocko,
what do you think of rucking as fitness versus just train up?
So for,
for people that don't know what rocking is rocking is putting a backpack on a
rucksack with a bunch of weight in it and walking long distances.
And,
and to be honest with you,
you really are jogging.
You know,
you're really going at a pretty good pace when you're doing it.
And that's it.
As far as rucking,
that's what running is,
because in the military they can bring the pain with Rachmat marches,
forced road marches is what they're called.
Yeah.
You'd be rocking all up.
You,
you'll be rocking till you don't want to be rocking.
And,
uh,
and so,
you know,
you'll do 20 mile force Roadmarch,
which is just,
you're on the road with a 50 pound pack,
just marching.
And,
uh,
so the thing is like anything else,
if you want to get good at it,
you got to do it right.
So if you want to get good at,
I people ask me why I need to get,
we're going to get it going to pull ups,
you know,
how do you get good at poems?
Do pull ups,
how do you get good at running run?
How do you get at swimming?
So I'm,
Oh,
you want to know how to get good at Jujitsu?
Did you do to,
you know,
get on the Mat and do Jujitsu a bunch.
Yeah.
Uh,
and if you want to get good at ruckinge,
at Hump in Iraq,
carrying weight over long distances,
rock,
cause there's all kinds of little things.
Got To get used to your feet.
Gotta get prepared,
you're going to get weird muscles,
your back's got to get stronger,
you're going to get,
you know,
calluses all over your feet.
It takes a special type of fitness regimen to get used to and ready for long
ruck marches.
And that special fitness regimen is rocking and lots of it.
So,
uh,
if you want to eventually you can augment that,
you know,
you can start doing squats,
you can start doing sprints and that'll help you,
you know,
that's fine.
But the foundation of the preparation for rock humping should be ruck humping.
And that's what's going to make you good at it.
So did you do that?
I did.
And rucking for me,
actually,
oddly enough,
is something that I was always good at.
No,
and it's weird because I wasn't the fastest sprinter and I wasn't the best long
distance runner,
which,
what does that make you?
Make you a loser,
right?
You can't win a sprint and you can't run a long distance run.
What's wrong with you?
Yeah.
You're kind of in the middle of that.
I was in the middle and what I realized was that was good for carrying a
rucksack.
Yeah.
And I got used to it too because I was a radio man.
So you always had,
I always had to carry a freaking radio,
you know,
30 pound radio with water,
uh,
batteries and you're just,
it's always heavy.
You're just sucking it up.
And so I got used to it.
I suppose it was that more than anything else,
you're like,
um,
you're seeing the movie tremors,
TV,
movie,
Trevor's Caleb,
there's a time at the end,
they were like,
man,
we need to,
we need to go to those mountains for those,
you know,
to,
to avoid the underground worms.
And they were like,
hey,
we could take the cat.
And he's like,
hey,
it's,
it's slow.
You know,
the cat is a big,
uh,
you know,
the Bobcat,
I don't actually know what a bobcat is.
I'm not sure.
I know what underground worms
that's dumps,
that's something completely different,
but their bed,
so they took the cat and the guy,
the guy was like,
no,
we can't take the get slower than hell.
And he's like,
it doesn't make a,
it can carry a ton though.
It,
you know,
it was,
he was like,
you,
you're like the cat.
So they hooked up this big trailer,
which is the Rock in your chair and you know,
and they,
and they drove everybody,
um,
you know,
to the mountains to walk.
No,
they're trapped on,
on roofs,
on a rooftop.
And they're like,
we're all going to starve up here.
We've got to make it to the mountains.
It's like nine miles.
They're like,
how are we going to get there?
We can't,
you know,
we can't run.
They're going to get us.
We can,
you know,
so they'll say we won't get the cat got,
and they were like,
oh,
it's too slow.
But they're like,
yeah,
but it can carry this big trailer.
You know?
And I used to say that in the seal teams and I got on,
my opinion was it was better to be built like a four by four and like a Porsche.
Yeah.
It was better to be,
it just cause you got to carry weight around durable.
Yeah.
What would you rather have working on a farm?
Uh,
Ford f three 50 or a Porsche.
Yeah.
I mean abortion is cool for the track when everything's all lined up and dialed
in the way it's supposed to be,
but you get any kind of terrain going on.
You want that for before and he wanted it bad.
And so that's why,
you know,
the seals,
guys that were kind of more a four by four than a Porsche,
yes,
you can be a better in the field in the real seal situations.
You know,
the,
the actual,
because the thing about that's,
that's,
it's a misconception about the seal teams is,
you know,
you see guys running on the beach and you see guys swimming in the ocean and
they never are carrying anything.
And that's just complete lie because every time you do anything in the seal
teams,
you're carrying a ton of weight with you.
And so you gotta be built like a four by four and not like a Porsche.
Yeah,
yeah.
Makes Sense.
So,
yeah,
he'd way rather someone like you then some sprinter who can run like a four to
40 but then you put some,
you know,
something on this
is actually,
you know what you,
you just want somebody that's durable.
Yeah.
Durable is the word.
And if they're a great athlete and they can have an awesome 40 time or they can
run a marathon,
but they're just durable,
it's awesome.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not trying to put parameters around the guys cause there's guys,
there was a guy when I was at team too and he was a guy actually went through
buds with and he was,
he's,
he's kind of a short guy and he was kind of had an odd body shape and so he kind
of looked,
he got to have almost like a little pudgy belly and uh,
he just was one of those guys.
And the funny thing is he could run faster than me and he could bench more than
me.
Yeah,
no kidding.
It was awesome.
I love that.
Yeah,
he's an awesome guy.
Awesome guy.
I said,
you know,
that's cool.
People say that about him because he's a little bit short and a little bit pouty
looking.
I'm like,
he can,
he can actually bench more than me and he can run faster than me.
He can beat me in all the runs.
So let's just be quiet
right
next.
Russian.
Jacqueline,
do you think that the military army,
Navy Air Force is a young man's game because he,
this,
this guy is 29 years old and he's about to join up.
He's about to get it on Yemen.
That's awesome.
Uh,
two answers to that question
and as usual with answers from me,
the dichotomy,
unfortunately there's a dichotomy and they oppose each other.
Uh,
first of all,
yes.
And anybody that says it's not a young man's game is not telling the truth
because it's a game where you're going to be on travel,
you're gonna be gone.
You'd be risking your lives at times.
You're going to have to
put up with a lack of comfort in your world.
You're going to be living in barracks.
I bet it's just going to be,
it's not,
it's not creature comforts,
right?
It's the military.
It's a semi spartan environment.
It's not the forgotten Highlander for the love of God,
but it's,
but it's definitely more spartan than what the average person has in regular
life.
So to anybody to say it's not a young man's game is,
is not telling the truth because it absolutely is.
And for me,
you know,
I joined when I was a kid when I was 18 years old and it was awesome.
I had no attachments in life.
Like I went to the MEP station with nothing with,
that's the,
that's the recruiting station where you actually go and I forget what it stands
for,
but it's where you actually leave for the military.
And I had no,
I had nothing there.
Oh,
do you need to store anything?
No.
What's your,
you know where you send your mail?
I don't get mail.
Hold Mail.
There is no mail that's sent to me with a blank slate.
And that's awesome.
You don't think about family,
you don't think about anything.
You just get in there and you'd get your job done.
And if they say,
hey,
we're going to deploy you tomorrow for the next eight years,
you say,
cool,
let's do you.
Let's bring it Dang and aid.
You have a obedient nature because you don't know any better.
You know,
you joined the military,
you're,
you're stoked.
You're getting a paycheck.
All of a sudden,
you know,
you got three hots and a cot.
It's all good.
You know?
Whereas when you're,
as you know,
when you're 17 years old and you're not quite putting things together yet Yab
and all of a sudden,
like I said,
you got a paycheck,
you've got three hots and a cot,
you ready to rock and roll.
They tell you what you do,
you do it.
That's good.
So it's a young man's game.
Now that being said,
of course there's a dichotomy to that and that is that the military,
is it always in need of guys that are mature and smart and have experienced in
life,
right?
That you need to have people like that.
Now you get them eventually through the military,
but it's also good to have people that won't raised in the military environment
so they can always have a little bit of an outer view and you can learn a little
bit from them.
But what you have to get over is all those things that the young guy can eat for
breakfast.
Right.
You know,
if you're 29 years old,
there's a decent chance you've had a pretty nice apartment somewhere.
There's a decent chance you slept in until you know,
nine 45 on the weekends.
There's a decent chance that you stayed out until two o'clock in the morning and
partied and you know,
brought a girl back and you slept in until nine and you might be doing that on
the regular,
you know what I mean?
You got some clothes,
you're watching cable TV,
you got all these things right.
And then the other,
the other part of that,
as you might have a family,
you know,
you might have life,
you might have kids at 29 years old.
Yeah,
you might be established,
you might have people relying on you,
not just financially but emotionally just to be there.
So how are you going to cut all that away?
That's the challenge for the older guy.
Now,
some older guys that are 29 years old,
they don't have any of that yet.
If,
if so best case scenario,
you got both.
Now that I'm not telling the 18 year olds to hold off on an on enlisting in the
military,
don't hold off.
Just get it done.
Get it done and you won't regret it unless you're,
unless you screw up and bring it upon yourself.
But if you are 29 and you can either overcome those obstacles of the things that
are going to,
the things that are going to,
things that are going to tear it you emotionally,
right?
They're going to tear it you emotionally.
Now what's cool is when you're in the military and you're raised in the
military,
you are
raised in such a way that those,
those distractions are easily overcome,
right?
You learn how to,
you learn how to compartmentalize those things.
At least I did to say,
you know what?
Hey,
I understand it's nice to stay home and sleep in on the weekend,
but I'm not going to do it.
Right?
It's nice to be able to hang out with your wife and kids,
but it doesn't matter to me compared to my job.
That's what you end up like,
which is slightly psychopathic,
but it's where you end up,
right?
It's where it's where I have to tell.
Yeah.
It's where I ended up was,
you know,
nothing else matters besides the seal teams.
And I don't care about anything else.
So if you want to be in my life,
cool.
You just got to do it around these giant parameters.
That's called the CLTs deal with it.
Yeah.
So join up my brother 29 years old.
Go and get after it.
Do that.
BTF
next question Jocko.
When do you cut your losses or give up on something and walk when and how
to decide to cut bait?
Not a quitter.
Too much brain damage.
Brain damage.
It's a word I've been hearing more from the corporate world actually is people
talk about when something's really hard to do and they're just causing brain
damage by trying to do it.
Uh,
and this was actually two questions.
It's obviously a metaphor,
obviously.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's okay.
It's a metaphor for it.
It's a metaphor for,
and I talk about when I was like beating my head against the wall,
and this is one of those things that confuses people because everyone hears,
including us in the seal teams,
we hear the mantra of never ever quit,
never quit.
And it's not just a mantra that we say,
it's actually,
it's actually what we believe.
Yeah.
And furthermore,
it's not just what we say and it's not just what we believe,
but it's literally how we act.
So
that that drive and that attitude of never quit.
It's a powerful force and it does push you over the edge to victory,
to victory in many cases.
But,
and there's always a dichotomy to just about everything.
There's a dichotomy to this too,
because over that attitude,
you have to layer something on top of that.
And that is
if basically strategic vision and understanding of
the battlefield as a whole.
So you know,
it's like the,
the,
the saying of win the battle,
lose the war.
This is the opposite,
right?
Win The battle.
Lose the war.
Meaning,
oh you,
you stick to it right now and you might win right now,
but in the long run you're going to lose.
This is the opposite where you,
you're going to say,
you know what,
I'm going to lose this battle right now,
but I'm going to win the war in the long run.
So you absolutely need to know when you got to stop beating your head against
the wall.
You've got to know that I personally draw my limit at 27 times after a beating
head against the wall 27 times on the 28th time,
I'm going to say,
you know what?
I bet there's another way to do this.
Or maybe this isn't a battle worth fighting.
Now the main reason
I think why people get caught in the trap of banging their head against the wall
or not knowing when to quit is because,
and again,
quit is a strong word and it's almost hard for me to say right now because it's
not knowing when to quit then.
I'm not talking about quitting.
I'm talking about,
yeah,
no,
I'm talking about making it a strategic assessment of an unwinnable situation
and deciding to disengage only so you can reengage with superior firepower and
crush the enemy.
Yeah.
So there's a big difference between that and quitting.
Quitting means you curl up into a ball and wait to die.
That's what quitting is.
And,
uh,
I know it's a board that under any circumstances,
so when do you,
when does it happen?
Where it happens?
Because people get emotional,
they get too emotional about whatever obstacles in front of them and they get
crazy about it and they start seeing the obstacle as not only the battle but
also as the war.
And they get lost in their own determination.
And I've seen this with some seal buddies of mine,
they are so determined that they will not stop even when it's completely
detrimental,
you know?
And,
and they do it with just about everything.
You know,
there'll be determined that anything,
you know,
there'll be hurting themselves.
Training,
there'll be,
you know,
determined to drink harder than anybody else.
They'll,
I mean,
it just,
anything you can throw at them and they're determined to win at that and it
actually losing.
Um,
so,
so how do you prevent that from happening is you have to,
again,
common theme here,
you have to detach.
You have to detach yourself.
You have to
be able to step back away from the problem enough to look at it from a strategic
viewpoint and say,
okay,
what's,
what's going on here?
What's the risk?
What's the reward?
How much am I willing to sacrifice right now?
And how is that sacrifice going to impact me tomorrow or the next day or next
week?
And then once you've detached and you've weighed and you've seen what the real
value of the this immediate objective is,
then you can assess and make a logical decision based not on your emotion but on
the actual impact of the situation in the overall strategic picture.
Yeah.
That,
um,
uh,
you're saying when you weigh the detriment and the in the rewards,
I think that that really makes it real clear when you can assess and be like,
oh,
all of this,
we're getting all this,
like all these,
this detrimental stuff when we're trying to get this,
you know,
this one benefit,
out of this person or out of this situation or whatever.
And when you're,
you're using up your resources are sacrificing more resources than you are
gaining ground,
then you know that that seems like a clear time to it.
At the very least,
start thinking about disengaging
and you got it.
You got to detach to bill notice out,
and I noticed this in Jujitsu all the time.
People try and pass pass and Garner sucks.
Simplest example.
Yeah.
People just like do one guard pass and it doesn't work and they do it again and
it doesn't work and they do it again.
It doesn't work.
They do,
they get and they go on and on and on until they're exhausted.
They get mounted and then they get put to dap
and it's because they were stubborn and they didn't detach and say,
I mean after you've tried to pass a guy's guard 14 times in a row the same way
and it hasn't worked,
why is it going to work the 15th time?
The answer is it's not.
Try something else.
Keep trying to think of a solid solid answer to that.
There is no solid and it's the same thing.
You should see this putting seals through training,
they'd get like bogged down in a bad situation and they would,
um,
they would,
they would just be,
start,
get focused on that one problem,
you know,
one room in the building,
they'd be like,
no,
send more guys into it.
Send more guys into it.
Everyone just getting sprayed with paint ball and put down in the training
operation and no two more guys.
And eventually everyone's just,
you know,
it's trading but everyone's dead and they're loading order up and you just
didn't,
they got focused on it and it costs them.
So the leader's got to be able to step back and detach and take a look at the
situation and decide,
you know what,
I'm going to go ahead and change course right now.
Not going to quit,
but I'm going to adjust.
Make a strategic adjustment.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
it's weird how those semantics can really change your outlook on the whole task.
When you,
when you use the word quit versus disengage or another one with quit,
like I said,
is give up,
you know,
like give it up.
I mean,
unless it's something negative like smoking or something like that,
you know,
quit smoking,
you're going to give up smoking,
that's good.
But obviously smoking to negative,
but any kind of task or anything that requires effort,
if you quit or quote unquote give up,
it's like,
it's hard to have that sound like a good thing,
you know?
Yeah.
And
one thing that's,
this is,
you know,
obviously it applies to combat,
it applies to Jujitsu as we just talked about.
But also,
you know,
you look at what you're doing day to day and the little things in your life that
you're trying to make work or in a business that you're trying to make something
happen.
And sometimes people get so addicted to their plan,
they get,
so their ego is wrapped around their plan.
Their plan is like 50% 50% tactics and technique and it's percent their own ego.
And so when you try it with that person's plan starts to fail,
guess what?
They don't want to let it go because it's all wrapped up in their ego.
So they just push it further,
push it further,
they push it further.
And especially if that person's in a senior position,
well then everyone's kind of just fallen in line and they're looking at them.
They all know,
they all know where they're at,
the bottom of the chain of command.
And I'll look into this person saying,
hey buddy,
it's not working.
Let's disengage and fall back in,
figure out a new plan of attack.
And then let's reapproach the target from a different angle.
Let's flank this target.
So if you're in a business,
if you're in a relationship relationship,
yeah.
And you've got a situation where you're trying to make something work a certain
way and it's not,
maybe it's,
you got to disengage and you've got to come with a different angle of attack so
that you can get the big wind.
We had the long run.
Yeah.
And with relationships,
obviously it's,
it's,
it's the same dynamic,
but it's different because,
um,
well it's the same because when you're in a,
let's say a boyfriend,
girlfriend relationship,
whatever you've been husband,
wife,
um,
you see it's not working.
Let's see.
One of them abusive.
Right.
Meanwhile,
the other one's trying to quote unquote make it work and if they end up leaving
all you gave up on him,
you know,
he,
you or you,
you could not,
and I don't think he'd ever say you'd quit the relationship,
but we'll just say you gave up on the relationship.
Right.
You know,
war.
He's been abusing her for 10 years already,
you know,
or in your case,
27 years or you know,
whatever the number is.
And um,
and he got to,
I do not abuse my wife.
All right.
Right.
But you know,
as far as your numbers go,
27,
um,
but again,
like if you say,
Oh,
you gave up on the relationship,
it's kind of like,
it's the girl's fault a little bit.
Like maybe she,
she,
she shouldn't have done that almost,
you know,
but um,
yeah,
you disengage and if you want to,
if you want to go for the win in that relationship and if you really want to
maintain the relationship,
don't let it be a husband,
wife relationship.
Maybe go back to being neighbors or something.
Like that,
even though in an abusive relationship that might not work.
But I'm just saying theoretically.
Yeah.
I'm not sure about all that.
Sure.
A man.
Uh,
but I do know that if you find yourself trying repeatedly to make something
happen and it's not happening,
try a different route.
You don't consider yourself a quitter.
Consider yourself a tech strategist or a tactician.
Good.
Next question.
Jocko.
In a fight,
MMA or otherwise,
would you substitute anger or rage for aggression?
Would I substitute anger or rage for aggression?
This isn't a fight,
MMA or otherwise,
that's important actually.
Yeah.
So we,
so just to clarify,
this means like instead of aggression,
is it okay to use anger or rage?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I think pretty obviously,
and people will just expect the answer to be for me,
the initial answer here is no,
and I would not substitute anger or rage for aggressiveness.
Uh,
I think obviously when you let rage takeover you,
you're not thinking anymore.
Yeah.
And the mind
is allegedly the most important weapon.
And I actually believe that to be true.
So if you let your rage and anger take over,
you're not using your mind and that's not good.
And you actually get to see this in MMA on a fairly regular basis because you'll
get somebody that is really good at talking smack.
Yeah.
And they'll get into the other person's head.
What does it mean to get the other person's head?
What does it do to them?
Does it make them sad?
No.
Does it make them not hate the opponent?
What does it do to them?
It makes them angry.
Yeah.
It makes them frustrated.
And that anger leads to frustration,
which leads to defeat.
So,
and again,
I think it's important to recognize that this doesn't just occur in MMA.
It occurs in everyday life.
And a good example is when you get in a conversation with somebody,
you get to debate with somebody.
You get in an argument with somebody,
the minute you get frustrated or angry or enraged,
users lost the argument.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
you might,
you might feel like you won.
Right.
But you will not win the argument.
You,
you lost the argument.
Yeah.
I mean at that that happens.
Okay.
Yeah.
In any,
uh,
yes,
but she fits in a debate men,
because it's an understood,
you're debating,
you're kind of against each other and then it's,
he just went off the rails basically.
Right?
Yeah.
It's not good to lose your temper in a debate,
in a conversation or in an MMA match.
Like if you're playing chess,
we were playing chess and I was talking smack to you.
You got frustrated in the flipped over the chess board.
Yeah.
You're right with the,
with the,
um,
you know,
a display of monumental power or whatever,
whatever that was [inaudible] Jackson for age.
Yes.
Yeah.
You won.
You lost
in a way.
Yeah.
You,
you absolutely.
This.
Um,
so,
uh,
I,
you know,
I talk about this all the time,
is that the rule is he'd never let your emotion get in control so you don't let
anger,
rage,
overwhelm your little brain.
Now here's the,
here's other side of that coin.
Here's the dichotomy.
And I don't think you can even argue against this because it's,
that's pretty sound argument,
right?
I mean what we just said.
I mean,
we've seen it,
we know we know for a fact,
but rules are made to be broken.
Um,
there are times,
okay,
we'd,
emotion can increase performance.
Yeah.
Right.
There absolutely are.
And I remember when I was a kid growing up,
the,
the Soviet Union was still just hardcore communist.
And when I would watch like the Olympics,
they would be like machines,
the Soviets,
no emotions.
And I thought,
man,
those guys are bad ass.
I wanted to be like that
and often brought him victories.
But I heard a quote when I was a kid and I,
I actually looked for it cause I wanted to bring it up.
I couldn't find it,
but it was something along the lines of this.
And that was that Soviet,
the Soviet athletes perform better in practice,
but the Americans perform better in the stadium.
Hmm.
So the Americans,
and that's not a universal statement and there's plenty of examples of the
Russians beaten Americans and whatever.
But there's also examples of where the Americans with their emotion and their
fire,
we're able to beat these Russians.
And,
I mean,
the greatest example would be the miracle on Iceland in Lake Placid,
New York in 1980 which is,
you know,
that was a bunch of college kids that were fired up to beat the hardened Russian
professional hockey team.
Yeah.
And it's because,
you know,
they kind of trained their emotions out of it and there's a great time to have
your emotions trained out of it.
You know,
there's a great time where you're like,
you know what,
I'm not gonna let my emotions play into this.
I heard a,
I heard something about tiger woods and his golf game and he's not thinking
about,
you know,
the,
the broad statement is when he's hitting a shot to golf,
he's not thinking about the last shot and he's not thinking about the next shot.
He's just thinking about that shot right there.
So there's no emotional of whether he's buying at or behind or nothing else.
He just is there on that one shot.
So
I think that,
you know,
we,
I think that people you meet Americans is the example I used.
But I think that people in general can use your emotion to,
to your advantage sometimes,
but
it does take control and it takes direction.
And also I think it's important to remember that it doesn't take long for that
extra fire of anger to go from making you stronger and faster to making you
slower and weaker both mentally and physically so you can get that burst.
Then,
you know,
you see this in fighting all the time where people punch themselves out.
You know,
they go,
they go level seven rage and they start swinging for the fence and excitement
even.
Yeah.
Or excitement.
They think the guy,
they think they got the guy in the,
in the hurt locker,
they come,
they bring the thunder for,
they get,
they get emotional.
Yup.
And I think on the mat when you get a guy that loses his temper,
when,
when somebody loses their temper with me on the map,
it's just a matter of time.
Like I just go,
okay,
cool.
He's got,
you know,
he's got three minutes left because he's going to be done.
So
yeah,
you've got to stay calm.
Now.
A couple of situations that I've seen or been a participant in,
uh,
and I'm pretty sure,
I was trying to remember this for sure,
but I was cornering Jeremy Stephens and if you don't know Jeremy Stevens is
little heath and MMA,
awesome guy,
stud fighter.
And we were training him at the time and he was fighting,
I,
I'm pretty sure it was against Marcus Davis,
who's a well-respected boxer,
really good MMA fighter as well,
but definitely known for his boxing.
Well,
Jeremy is known for his striking as well.
He's a very powerful striker and he's got unbelievable one punch knockout power
Jeremy does.
So I was and Jeremy and it was a really,
really close fight,
Amit.
It was a,
I didn't know if he was winning or losing,
I think it was leaning towards Marcus actually.
And there's three rounds in MMA in this,
in this fight.
And in between the second and the third round,
I got in the ring,
got in the cage with Jeremy and I,
I did the full on,
you know,
in his face and I know I gave him the,
hey listen,
this is what's going on.
This guy across the ring from you is taking money off your kid's table is taken
food off your kid's table,
was going to take the roof off their heads.
He's taken everything that you've worked for.
He's going to take it from you right now.
You got to get pissed.
You got to go in there,
you got to destroy him.
And I got,
you know,
I got to give him a fired up speech like that and you could see it switch in his
eyes.
He realized like he went into a rage of I need to kill this guy.
And he came out that round and knocked him out.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And that's one.
I'll tell you another one I saw that was,
it was the same.
So it was,
it was Carlos Condit versus Rory Macdonald.
And this was,
this was the first time they fought.
I pretty sure it was in Canada.
I was there,
I forget who I was cornering,
but I was there and I was done with corn or whoever's cornering.
And
I want to say it was Peterson Bodegas Corner,
I think it was up in Canada.
But um,
so Carlos condit versus Roy MacDonald and Carlos,
who's the veteran is going up the get the kid,
you know,
Roy McDonald was in kind of an,
he was an unknown,
but he was definitely the younger,
I think he was 20 years old.
You're just a kid.
No offense Rory.
But he was young,
you know what I mean?
Bad Ass.
But young and Carlos was the vet,
you know what I mean?
He was a veteran,
grown man with a wife and kids and man,
Rory was getting the better versus in front of Rory is hometown.
Well I don't know if it's his hometown,
but it was a Canada.
And so the crowd was absolutely supporting Rory,
at least.
I'm pretty sure I remember this right.
I'm sorry if I don't,
but it seemed like the crowd was on the side of Rory Macdonald.
Hmm.
So in between.
So I'm just watching the fight,
but I had snaked some really good seats.
So I had a really good view,
by the way,
when I go to UFC,
thanks Dana white and the rest of the crew,
like I sneak it is some awesome seats after I get done corner again,
people.
So thank you.
So I was sitting,
you know,
in the second row or something,
phenomenal seat that I'd snuck into.
And because they throw you in the cheap seats when you're,
when you're cornering people and you come out to watch the fights and yeah,
you're up in the nosebleeds,
which was,
is it cool?
So I just get aggressive and tactically move to better positions,
which is using the second row right behind the press box.
Sure.
So I'm sitting down there and I'm watching the fight and Greg Jackson is
cornering Carlos condit.
Now,
if you don't know anything about Greg Jackson,
he's,
he's present like guy.
And I've actually,
uh,
going back in the day,
going way back in the day when Dean and I were competing all the time in the
kind of the sole cow scene of grappling,
we would,
we do every competition there was competing all the time.
Grappling,
I don't even remember there were,
there are so many of them that we do at hand.
Uh,
Greg Jackson would bring guys out to,
to fight to compete.
And so like we wrestled against these guys,
you know,
are,
we did submission,
grappling gets these guys.
So I kind of knew him from that.
And then surprisingly one time when the UFC was in San Diego,
I was at work at the seal teams and someone called and said,
hey,
there's a,
there's a guy from the UFC here,
do you want to give them a tour of,
you know,
he wants a tour there.
The UFC set up a tour of the seal teams.
They want to show him around like the facility facilities,
you know,
the whatever soum some guns,
just the gear,
whatever.
So I show up and it's Greg Jackson.
And you know,
we kind of had a little bit of recognition,
but,
uh,
anyways,
Greg Jackson and you know,
you kinda hear this stuff about Greg Jackson all the time that he's this really
nice guy and that he's super mellow and that he's really humble.
Well,
it's all freaking true.
He's a super nice guy.
He's super humble,
he's just a fantastic guy.
And,
uh,
I gave him a tour and so we kind of got to know each other and then,
you know,
going fast forward now in the UFC,
I,
I've,
I've cornered him several times.
I don't know how many times I've against him,
you
know,
against them.
My fighters are fighting his fighters.
Yeah.
Uh,
and you know,
like I said,
he's a really like a really mellow and a zen like guy.
If you watch them in the corners of his fights,
he's always like that,
just very steady and hey,
this is what you need to do and you need to watch out for this or whatever.
So I'm watching this fight and like I said,
Carlos Condit versus Roy MacDonald.
Carlos is not winning,
right?
He's not winning.
And between
the second and the third round,
Greg Jackson goes full Bismarck or boat on content.
I mean he is yelling at him,
he is in his face.
He's pointing at him,
he's waving his finger.
He's just going nuts on him.
And I was like,
damn,
Greg Jackson is bringing the heat and sure enough he amped up Carlos Condit
Carlos condit came out and finished Rory and the third which have a fight,
he was definitely going to lose.
So what you see there is emotion helping to win in that situation.
Yeah.
And uh,
actually when the fight was over,
I saw Greg and I just kind of said something to him,
you know,
like,
hey,
you went full Berserker Bodog are Carlos?
And he said,
yeah,
he's like,
I had to do it.
It is funny.
It's,
you could see it.
It almost seemed like he'd never done it before.
I don't know.
Maybe we'll have to have Greg on at some point he can tell the story.
But he said something along the lines of,
you know,
I,
I had to do it and it worked.
So you know what,
he had a big smile and,
and that was working it.
And it definitely indeed it did work.
Yeah.
And those,
would you,
do you think,
I mean there's total guess,
but do you think that's because those just happened to be the exceptions or is
it because really the formula kind of seems like
here's the emotion and then here's all the logic and the skill and the planning,
implementation of,
of you know,
game plans and all this,
all this stuff that you're going to use in your,
in your mind.
And here's the emotion.
It's like it's like us a little spark plug or something and then I'm sure the
emotion can go up,
but the skill got to go up proportionately.
And once he'd start to do this,
when the emotion takes over,
that's when you know when you're going to fail or,
or to take advantage.
So think there's a sweet spot in there where for moments in time,
emotion and even border lining on rage,
which I think range is a little bit strong because I think rage,
you lose your clarity,
but anger,
which is you can still have some clarity of what you're doing.
Right.
So I think you can actually,
that can be utilized appropriately at the right times.
And I think these times,
you know,
like I talked about with Jeremy,
I had to provoke some anger out him.
Yeah.
You know,
I had to provoke and it absolutely helped him.
He's gonna lose that fight.
Yeah.
And it's the same thing with Carlos.
Carlos was absolutely going to lose that fight if he didn't do something
different.
If he didn't,
you know,
it's like,
it's like hitting the turbo button.
It's like hitting up when nitrous oxide,
right?
It's not going to take a hit in the blue,
the nitrous oxide blower.
It's only going to get you,
it's only gonna make you go hard for another,
what is it,
another two minutes or,
well,
without nitrous oxide,
it's not very long at all.
But yeah,
but with,
but with anger,
you know,
it can make you go for another,
whatever.
Maybe it's,
maybe it's two minutes and this is something else.
Have you ever missed like a heavy single,
like,
like Yoga,
you're lifting,
you're deadlifting or you're doing power cleans or something and you miss a
heavy signal.
No,
I,
no,
you've never heard so.
So this is another easy way to prove it,
man.
I miss a heavy signal sometimes and sometimes I just get angry.
It's true.
And I just have to bring the anger and I start getting fired up and I start
thinking about things that make me angry.
Yeah.
And I get over that bar and I ripped that thing off the floor.
Like I hate it.
Yes.
And it absolutely makes me stronger that moment.
So is that a dress?
Probably adrenaline and it's probably the same thing that pumped into Marcus's
or oriented Jeremy's head.
It's probably the same thing that park pumped into Carlos's head.
But it's crazy because despite getting punched,
despite getting beaten,
despite having someone,
you know,
trying to destroy you in front of a large crowd of people,
none of that was able to spark the,
was able to spark the adrenaline as much as some kind of,
uh,
tap into the emotional portion of your mind to bring out just enough rage to get
out there and get that job done once and for all.
Yeah.
And yeah,
and that's really the key there.
Just enough rage,
especially when you're talking about,
um,
something that requires technique.
When you say lifting your,
you're like power clean for example.
And um,
I remember it was in,
in college and I was going from my one rep Max and yeah,
you feel a couple of times,
but for the sake of saving time and stuff,
you can,
they only give you three times won't in my case.
Then they were like,
you have to get it three times.
Um,
so the first time I had gotten all of them,
I was pretty solid at Parkland liens at that time.
So I was getting all of them.
And then I got to that point,
um,
and I didn't get it.
It was 300 it 300.
I weighed one 85 at the time,
uh,
to 98.
Are you looking for props right there?
Yeah.
We'll give you props,
props,
tech.
Maybe when he was talking earlier about when you name drop and stuff.
Yeah.
That's what it,
I did.
No,
I did that on purpose.
I did that on purpose because if I were,
if I were to go out of my way to leave out that number.
True,
true.
You know,
you wanted to know,
you wanted to know how much I was doing.
I knew you're going to say it.
It didn't matter if you want it to hell anyway,
it doesn't matter.
Nonetheless,
the first time I failed and everyone's like,
no,
you got this,
you got this.
And I had this getting rotten wood whose name?
Uh,
pro blonde hair,
like use,
like he's,
this tough guy could hit real hard and he would always get nuts and he'd be
like,
you got tissue,
didn't you know,
you're this and that,
you know,
making me mad or whatever.
And I didn't outwardly express any kind of anger,
but I felt that anger and power plane takes technique.
That's the thing.
It's not like,
it's just um,
you know,
like,
I dunno like even bench has some technique but is,
I mean everything has technique,
but right.
Power clean takes a little bit more technique than other lefts.
Yeah.
So it was just the perfect amount of rage,
you know,
and that's going to depend on what kind of person you are.
Like Jeremy Stevens and you could tell just even the way he trains,
he uses some rage in there,
you know,
as opposed to Eh,
Rory Mcdonald for example.
Seemingly.
I Dunno,
I don't watch them train all the time or nothing,
but it seems like he's super methodical,
you know,
in rage or anger or whatever isn't used as much of a part as someone like Jay.
Um,
Jeremy Season fight with,
uh,
with uh,
Robbie Lawler.
Yeah.
Homes like crazy.
We're all bored of just,
yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Marie's nuts,
man.
He's the way they train up there at tri stories.
I spent like the the weekend or it was like half a week or whatever with them
with frozen and Rory and its heat.
Fry's has this head,
you know how guys will hold mitts.
I'm sure they hold mitts and stuff,
but he has this head that you hit the head instead of the myth.
I was like,
well it seems like,
oh that's not that.
Like it seems kind of obvious.
So I never seen no one do that and it made way more sense because I've hit mits
before and then when you go to sparks like it,
it's kind of weird.
You got to get used to the difference between hitting mitts and hitting
someone's head.
So I thought,
man,
that's clever man.
These guys are good.
They're smart up here in Canada.
Yeah,
respect to those guys.
I mean,
I respect all the guys that get into that get in the UFC and fight,
man.
It's awesome to watch.
And that,
that Lawler a Mcdonald's fight was just,
was just insane.
It was insane.
You know,
she'd watch that fight if you haven't met anyone that hasn't watched that fight,
could watch that fight for him to see a couple of warriors.
Just bringing the,
bringing it all and leaving it all right there in the cage.
Go Watch that fight.
Uh,
so did you get the power clean?
I got the parking.
Yes.
And then here's the thing about that power clean.
So you I,
yeah,
I got it right.
And so you go up and he's like,
hey,
you got to,
you go up in weight.
The next one was like three o' three like super small weights,
you know,
cause you want to get it.
Yeah.
Just so you can get the three Oh three not even close.
Everything was spent on that.
Is that one didn't we?
It was at the all time life life.
I just disengage.
That's all that was just disengaged and I see where it's at.
I'm good with that.
All right.
I feel like we should go on to the next question.
I think we got time for about one more,
wouldn't they?
I think so.
Okay.
Jocko is the ability to switch on and off a personal feature or is it a trained
skill?
Is this confused with the term beast mode?
What causes that switch to flip
the overdrive,
the beast mode,
the full on destroyer
that will not stop.
I think it's actually is,
it is something that's learned,
I think,
and I think it's a hard lesson.
I don't think everyone gets it.
I think some people go through life without ever getting it.
Yeah,
and I'll tell ya,
it's 18 important lesson nature.
It's critical lesson
each.
The thing that allows you to go the extra distance to dig just a little bit
deeper,
push
a little harder,
get after it.
And
like many other things in life,
there's a dichotomy because it actually takes,
in my opinion,
two opposing forces to bring it to life.
It takes both emotion and logic.
Okay.
For you to reach your match maximum potential to,
to really give everything you have and go beyond your limits.
Because both emotion and logic,
they're going to reach their limitations.
And when one fails,
iin rely on the other one.
So
when it doesn't make sense,
logical sense to go on,
that's when you got to use your emotion.
That's when you got to use that anger,
that frustration,
that fear to push yourself harder to push yourself to say,
I don't stop.
And when your feelings are screaming that you've had enough,
and when you think you're going to break emotionally,
you got to override that emotion with the concrete logic and willpower that
says,
you know what?
Okay,
I don't stop.
So you,
you fight the week emotions with the power of logic and you fight the weakness
of logic with the power of emotions
and in the balance of those two.
Yeah.
That's where you find the strength and the tenacity and the,
the guts to say to yourself,
yeah,
I don't stop.
Yeah.
And you won't.
And I think that's about it for tonight.
So thanks to everyone for tuning in and listening to us.
Okay.
If you want to continue these conversations,
you want to join in these conversations,
you connect with us through the interwebs on Twitter.
I'm at Jocko Willink and of course,
Echo Charles is add echo.
Charles,
thanks for leaving reviews of the podcast on iTunes and of the book on Amazon
and most of all
to everyone that's out there tuning in,
listening.
You got your headset on,
you getting in the zone.
Thank you for getting after it.
And so until next time,
this is Jocko and deco
out.